let's go next to our caller from the
nine one two area code caller from nine
one two who's this hello David this is
Sebastian I'm from Savannah Georgia oh
go ahead Sebastian hey I had a quick
question on your outlook of the midterms
with the especially with all of the
elections and all of the new all the new
[Music]
sorry all of the new investigations and
stuff like that with all of the
especially the Republican and I was
wondering I know you gave a video out
about you thought the Democrats didn't
win as much as you today thought we
thought we would and if your view points
have changed with what has happened with
all the okay yes so I here's here's my
view so if you look historically the
Democratic pickups in the House are some
of the biggest that Democrats have ever
had in house elections I think now we're
up to plus the earlier +32
objectively by the numbers that's big
the Senate right now it looks like
Democrats are down one seat after
Kyrsten Sinema was actually found to
have defeated martha mcsalley
that's a loss but when you look at which
third of the Senate was up in these
particular midterms that's actually not
really that bad so I think that on paper
there was a blue wave of sorts and these
were good results +7 when it comes to
governorships millions and millions more
votes for Democrats than for Republicans
what I meant when I said it wasn't what
some were hoping for is that when you
have someone as incompetent as ignorant
as unbalanced as embarrassing as Donald
Trump and his administration in power
any rational person would start to
internalize the idea that we're just
gonna crush them I mean we're gonna take
over everything and it just it's not
always possible because of how the
Senate elections are set up president is
only every four years so I think that
it's important to understand that number
one
the victories were significant given
what was available and historically but
I sympathized with the idea that things
are so crazy that we would like to
imagine that we could like fix it more
quickly than it's actually able to be
fixed yeah that's very true okay thank
you very much I really the call and a
good a good point and a good question